rendre impossible la traversée
clandestine de la manche entre le nord
de la france et l'angleterre
c'est en clair ce que prévoit cet accord
entre paris et londres pour y arriver
les patrouilles françaises vont être
doublées dès mardi prochain de nouveaux
moyens technologiques seront aussi
déployés le long des plages françaises
des drones et des radars vont être
utilisés pour mieux surveiller la manche
par ailleurs il y aura bientôt un
nouveau système d'asile qui sera fermé
juste et une nouvelle législation sera
mis en place l'année prochaine
le royaume uni s'est engagé à faire un
investissement financier supplémentaire
de 31,4 millions d'euros pour soutenir
les efforts importants de la france
contre les traversée irrégulière
un nouvel accord entre le royaume uni et
la france qui fait suite à des traités
bilatéraux déjà signé en 2004 et 2018
des textes qui prévoit le financement
par londres d'une partie de la lutte
contre cette immigration clandestine en
échange du renforcement de la présence
policière près des ports du nord de la
france
un dossier migratoire qui a été
régulièrement source de tensions entre
paris et londres
le royaume uni a souvent accusé la
france de ne pas s'impliquer
suffisamment pour empêcher des
traversées des traversées de la manche
qui ne cessent de se multiplier avec
leur lot de drames il y à un mois encore
quatre personnes dont deux enfants
ils sont mortes noyées dans le naufrage
de leur embarcation de fortune à l'aide
de canots pneumatiques de kayak ou
encore de gilet de sauvetage pas moins
de 6000 200 migrants ont tenté entre le
1er janvier et le 31 août dernier de
rejoindre les côtes britanniques depuis
le nord de la france